for many of us our strongest and at the
same time vagus desire is to be more
creative and when we think about what it
would mean to be creative we arrive at a
dauntingly fixed range of jobs we might
be visually creative and so we identify
that we might want to be a painter a
photographer a filmmaker a designer or
an architect or we might be
intellectually creative and so we want
to be a novelist a journalist or an
academic or we might be musically
creative and so we want to start a band
or we might be sensorily creative and so
we want to start a restaurant
the problem is that securing any of
these jobs is statistically speaking
almost impossible
we can end up blocked sure of what we
want to be yet also unable to break into
our chosen field
we end up with what we can call a
fixation rather than simply an interest
to signal the mixture of inner certainty
and outer impossibility
the solution to such fixations lies in
coming to understand more closely what
we are really creatively interested in
because the more accurately and
precisely we fathom what we truly care
about the more we stand to discover that
our creative interests and their
associated pleasures actually exist in a
far broader range of occupations than we
have until now been used to entertaining
it's a certain lack of understanding of
what we're really after and therefore a
relatively standard and obvious reading
of the job market that pushes us into a
far narrower tunnel of options than is
warranted when we properly grasp what
draws us to one creative job we stand to
identify qualities that are available in
other kinds of employment as well
what we really love isn't this specific
job but a range of themes we first
located there normally because this job
was the most conspicuous example of a
repository of them which is where the
problem started because over-conspicuous
jobs tend to attract too much attention
get oversubscribed and are then in a
position to offer only very modest
salaries
yet in reality the qualities can't only
exist there they are necessarily generic
and will be available under other less
obvious guises once we know how to look
imagine the person who's become heavily
invested in the idea of becoming a
journalist the very word journalist has
become a coveted badge that captures
everything they feel they want from a
young age the job suggested glamour and
stimulation excitement and dynamism they
got used to parents and uncles and aunts
referring to them as future journalists
however the sector now happens to be in
terminal decline and pitiably
oversubscribed a block and a lot of
angst is the result
the recommended move is to pause the
fruitless job search and unpaid
internships and ask oneself what might
truly be appealing in one's intuitive
excitement around being a journalist
what are the pleasures ones really
seeking here and might they exist
somewhere else and somewhere more
favorable in the world of work
we're prone to a very natural vagueness
here we often just like the broad sound
of a given job but if we analyze the
pleasures involved we start to prise off
the lid and look more assiduously at
what's on offer
once scrutinized we find that journalism
offers some of the following pleasures
an ability to engage with serious
political and sociological issues to
analyze policy to write up thoughts with
elegance and to be respected for one's
critical powers
once such elements are clarified it
becomes clear that they cannot be
uniquely connected to the sector that we
call journalism the combination can't
only exist and isn't only needed in
newspapers and magazines it's not really
tied to any particular sector the
qualities can and do turn up in a lot of
other places for instance a financial
investment firm might have a huge need
to analyze emerging markets and explain
their potential and their possible
weaknesses to clients
a university might need to analyze and
understand changes in its competitive
environment and explain these in clear
and compelling ways to its staff
an oil company might need to analyze its
future likely employment needs and
convey this to its recruitment teams
around the world
these industries don't sit under the
heading of journalism but they all have
needs and opportunities which in fact
offer exactly the same pleasures which
were initially and rather superficially
associated with journalism
investigation reveals that the pleasures
we are seeking are more mobile than we
initially suppose they don't have to be
pursued only in the world of say the
media they may be more accessible more
secure and more financially rewarding
when pursued in quite different sectors
of the economy
this is not an exercise in getting us to
give up on what we really want the
liberating move is to see that what we
want exists in places beyond those we
had identified
the same analysis could be run around
teaching this doesn't it turns out have
to be done in a primary or a high school
one might in essence be a teacher in an
aeronautics conglomerate you have to
teach new recruits about the nature of
the industry or a wealth management firm
there you have to teach executives about
how to deal with difficult clients or
someone who is fixated on politics might
realize that the pleasures they seek
influencing societal outcomes are as
much available and better rewarded and
maybe more consequential in a job with a
tourist board or an oil exploration
company
this can look like a climb down but only
if we don't understand well enough what
we're actually looking for
the surprising liberating side of
analyzing your search for a job by what
pleasures you seek is that it reveals
that it can never be a particular
industry sector that's the key to
finding a job we can love
because when properly understood a
creative pleasure is thankfully generic
and can therefore truly turn up in many
different and initially unexpected
places
careful knowledge of what we love sets
us free to love more widely
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life
click now to learn more
you